Hey everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we'll be going for video
number two in the systems design 3.0
series and we'll cover paste bin. So
before I get into it, I'm going to cover
a few pieces of feedback. Uh so you know
obviously we can improve these videos
because otherwise there's not really any
point in me making them. I want to be as
helpful to you guys as I can be. So
let's go through the feedback. Point
number one, which I heard from probably
the majority of people was that it felt
a little bit too much like a lecture for
a couple of reasons. One is that I
didn't really make a lot of jokes during
the slides. And number two is that you
couldn't see my face. I will now retort
to both of those things. I am going to
make more jokes, but I should say you
guys all have Tik Tok attention spans.
Uh if you need me to make jokes and uh
you want this to be a little bit more
accessible, don't blame me when the job
market gets flooded. The whole point of
coding was that it wasn't supposed to be
that accessible and it was hard and
that's why we got paid lots of money.
Now I don't know. We're all going to get
replaced by chat GBT in like two years
anyway. So, what does it matter? Number
two is that people want to see my face.
Now, personally, I also need a visual
aid sometimes. However, that is for
something a little bit different than
systems design interview prep. If you
really need to see my face, I'll put it
up on the side of the screen. That being
said, I'm literally just reading off my
screen directly. So, I'm not going to
make any eye contact with the camera. If
you need to see me go talk, whatever.
Fine. So be it. The last piece of
feedback that I received was that uh it
was a little bit hard to focus on some
of the diagrams because it was hard to
actually point out what I was talking
about as I was going through it. A lot
of people want me to bring back out the
iPad, which I'm pretty hesitant to do
because that is going to get in the way
of me reading the script. I can't read
the script and then pause for like 5
seconds and underline stuff on the iPad.
I could do a bunch of editing, but
actually syncing up me like drawing
stuff versus me talking is surprisingly
annoying. Uh so what I'm going to do
instead is make more incremental
diagrams where I kind of uh continue to
expand them as I talk. Again, I'll take
feedback on that at the end of the
episode. I appreciate it. Uh but please
bear with me as I continue to figure out
this series. Finally, uh I am going to
be shameless about this. Uh the channel
memberships are open. Um as I get more
and more comments here, they're becoming
harder and harder for me to respond. Uh
so I'm going to give a oneweek SLA to
the channel members uh regarding their
comments. if you do need help or you
just want to, you know, help me out with
my crippling addictions. That being
said, I'm done rambling. Uh, let's go
ahead and get into the video for today.
If you haven't watched it already,
please consider checking out last week's
tiny URL video. We'll be building off
the design that we built there. We'll do
a short review of that design as well,
but if it doesn't completely make sense,
I'd highly recommend checking out the
full video. Let's get into the
functional requirements for PBIN. At its
core, PBIN is extremely similar to Tiny
URL. However, this time instead of
passing in a long URL to make into a
short URL, a user passes our application
a long string of text called a paste. In
exchange, they're going to receive a
short URL that can be used to view that
paste in the future. Note that once
again, we won't be covering click
counting per short URL in this video.
That will be the topic of the next one.
Here's a first attempt at describing our
API. We have one function where a user
passes in text to our backend as well as
an arbitrary expiration time for their
paste and receives a short URL in
return. And then we also have a second
function where a user passes in the
short URL and receives back the long
string of text. In reality, the
interactions between the client and the
server are going to look a bit different
than this, but we're going to revisit
this later in the video. For the
capacity estimates, I'm going to use
identical ones from last video. That
means that we're going to assume that
per month users create 600 million
pastes. It also means that per month
users are going to load pace 10 billion
times. One additional piece of
information is the average pace size.
For our purposes, we'll assume it's 100
kilobytes, which is around 100,000
characters of text. I'll set a seemingly
arbitrary maximum pace size of 5 GB,
though eventually we're going to explain
why making it any larger would really
complicate things. Let's review our
design for tiny URL. When building a URL
shortener, there are two main
application flows. creating a short URL
and getting redirected after navigating
to a short URL. We'll discuss URL
creation first. When a client first
wants to create a URL, the request gets
routed to a load balancer. In our last
episode, we wanted to ensure that all of
our design layers were horizontally
scalable. For this reason, we scaled out
to many different application servers,
each of which could handle any user's
requests. To route requests, we use
multiple roundrobin load balancers.
While we may not need multiple load
balancers from a throughput perspective,
it's best to avoid using one load
balancer and letting it become a single
point of failure. Since we don't expect
our load to be fluctuating too much
right now, our clients can be statically
configured with a list of load balancers
and our load balancers can be statically
configured with a list of application
servers. From the load balancers, the
client's request gets proxied to an
application server, which then randomly
chooses a database node to handle a
query. Each database node is
preconfigured with a range of short URLs
and the selected node will assign an
available one to the incoming request.
This brings us to the read path. When
passing a short URL to figure out the
corresponding long one, we again go
through the load balancer to an
arbitrary application server. Because
the mapping of a short URL to a database
node is deterministic, an application
server can easily figure out which node
it must contact when figuring out the
long URL associated with the short URL.
From there, the server reaches out to
the proper database node and issues a
redirect back to the client. One final
piece to note on this read path is our
look aside caching layer. Not dissimilar
to the ladies in my DMs, everyone wants
to fetch my tiny URL. Because certain
short URLs can get hot, the application
server will first read a distributed
Reddis cache for each result before
checking the database on a cache miss.
In this event, the application server
will also populate the cache with the
value from the database. Now, let's go
through a very highle design of PBIN.
The majority of it looks extremely
similar to Tiny URL. However, there are
some differences. We've added an object
store as well as a content delivery
network. We'll go over both of these in
much more depth in a few minutes, so
please bear with me. Let's go through
our client flows now. We'll start with
creating a new paste. To do this, we'll
first have our client upload their paste
to S3. When this is completed, we can
reach out to the server asking for a
short URL corresponding to the paste URL
in S3. This part should be just like
tiny URL. On the read side, our client
resolves paste links in S3 by passing in
a short URL, which is the same as in our
URL shortener design. Then it reaches
out to the CDN in order to resolve paste
content. At a high level, this problem
looks really similar to tiny URL. We're
passing some content to a server and the
server is returning us back a short URL
for it. When we pass in the short URL,
we fetch the original content back.
You'd be right. It is super similar, but
there are some differences. The main
differentiator is actually going to be
the paste itself, which can be a fairly
big object. 100 kilobytes is not small
by any means. Another important property
of the paste is that it's immutable.
Once a user creates a paste, it can't be
edited. So, should we just treat our
paste as if it's a super long URL? The
answer here is likely going to be no. If
we do, that means that each paste is
going to be passed from a client to the
application server and then into the
database. If so, that server is going to
have to handle more load than bonnie
blue, which seems like a pretty poor
idea. Technically, it's possible.
Postgress, for example, can handle up to
1 GB of text in a single database row.
So, why shouldn't we do it? There are
many reasons not to store big pieces of
text in a typical transactional database
like Postgress. So, let's go through
them. Under the hood, the database is
organizing its data in fixed-sized
pages, which can be cached in memory for
faster reads. When we store these large
text blobs in database rows, we can make
row sizes a bit unpredictable, causing
fewer of them per page and messing with
our cache efficiency. It's also worth
noting that if you have to write massive
pieces of text all the time and are
doing so while grabbing locks, you're
going to be holding those locks for a
while. Another thing that's going to
degrade significantly is replication. We
have to take all of the data on our
leader database and send it to our
followers. The more data that there
there is, the longer this is going to
take. In addition, it's very common to
run a database in the cloud that has
replicas in multiple availability zones
in order to have some ability to
withstand natural disasters. In this
event, you may pay significant fees for
the network bandwidth that you use
between them. Lesson learned,
replicating is expensive and may get in
the way of your fatfire dreams that we
all have. Unfortunately, you cannot use
a condom to lower your cloud bill,
unlike replication. Generally speaking,
when you have large immutable files, the
proper place to put them is in an object
store. The best examples here are going
to be S3, Google Cloud Storage, and
Microsoft Azure storage. I've posted a
lot of videos devoted to why object
stores are so cheap, but to quickly
summarize, they use cheaper types of
discs and also special types of fault
tolerance mechanisms that assume that
the stored content is immutable. They're
also super easy to use as the burden of
scaling them out is handled by your
cloud provider. When using an object
store, you upload the content to it and
it provides you a link in return. In our
case, we want to upload a txt file to S3
and then store the pointer in our URL
mappings database for later retrieval.
Let's look at an updated database schema
here. When fetching a paste for a given
short URL, we'll first fetch its URL in
S3 and then make a call to S3 to
download the content. Once again, we'll
store our expiration time in the row.
When claiming a URL, we can just find
rows that are expired and reclaim them
for a new paste. How does our paste
content actually get into the object
store? One option that we have is to
just send the paste data to our
application server via a typical HTTP
request, which can then upload that data
to S3. However, this is going to be
fairly wasteful. If a server is handling
hundreds or more clients at once, it's
going to be receiving a lot of large
payloads at a time, which is going to
saturate its network link. This would
also just generally slow down the short
URL creation process, as we need to add
an additional hop over the network for
this large blob of text. In comparison,
we could just have our client writing
directly to and reading directly from S3
on the right path. This adds some
complexity as we need to provide the
client with something called a
pre-signed URL because we don't trust
our clients. They can't have access to
our Amazon cloud configuration in order
to be able to freely upload content to
our S3 buckets. However, we can get
around this. When using Amazon S3, a
server can create something known as a
signed URL and pass it back to the
client. The client can then submit an
HTTP put request using that signed URL
to upload a file. Note that Amazon S3
only supports uploading files up to 5 GB
in size via a single request.
Fortunately, I capped our pace size at 5
GB in the functional requirements. For
bigger files than that, we need
something known as a multi-art upload,
which complicates things a bit. We'll
save this for a video in a few weeks
from now where we actually upload larger
files. Let's go through the flow in a
little bit more detail. To start, our
client is going to reach out to the
server asking it for a signed URL. The
server then creates the signed URL
locally based on its AWS credentials and
returns it back to the user. The user
can then finally upload the content to
S3. In our system, we have to support
three main endpoints. The first is
actually just what we discussed, which
is a request from the client to the
server in order to generate a pre-signed
URL. While we could have the client
specify the object name in S3, it may be
more simple to just let the server do
it. Note that we'll also need to pass in
the proposed expiration time. It's not
really relevant right now, but we're
going to touch upon why we need this in
our deep dive section. Next, we also
have an endpoint that takes in an S3 URL
from the client and assigns a short URL
to it. Finally, we have one more
endpoint that takes in a short URL from
the client and returns the corresponding
S3 URL. While this last part doesn't
require interacting with our backend,
the client can now read the content in
the S3 bucket via a request to Amazon.
Note that if we're loading content from
a publicly readable bucket, we only need
a pre-signed URL for adding files, not
for viewing them. You may also notice
that we've basically already built
endpoints 2 and three. They're pretty
much identical to what we did in tiny
URL. Hence, in this video, we're going
to focus on two things. Clients
uploading PACE to S3 and clients
accessing PACE from S3. When uploading a
pace, the first thing that we'll do is
fetch our pre-signed URL. This requires
an API call to our application servers.
After that, the client can directly
upload their paste to the object store.
Finally, we can go through our typical
flow of claiming a short URL for our S3
object URL, which you should now be
pretty familiar with. When loading a
paste, the beginning of the process
looks very similar to tiny URL. The
client passes a short URL to the server
and the server fetches the corresponding
S3 URL. Note that despite us needing to
make an extra call to get the content
itself, it's still important to have
Reddus here to make sure fetching the S3
URL is as quick as possible. Once the
client has this, it needs to load the
file. While it could reach out directly
to S3, it can instead reach out to our
content delivery network, which is
basically a geodistributed cache for
static content. If the CDN contains the
file, it'll return it. Otherwise, it'll
proxy the request to S3, fetch the file,
and then pass it back to the user. When
a client wants to upload a paste to S3,
it must first request a signed URL from
the server before the server returns it.
Why doesn't it ask the database to claim
a short URL for that paste? We may
actually not want to do this due to
partial failures. Looking at the left
side of our diagram, what if the client
were to fail before it could upload the
paste to S3? Then we'd have an S3 URL
that points to absolutely nothing in our
database. a client that accesses the
corresponding short URL would be super
confused and also that short URL would
now be unavailable to be claimed.
Instead, we're probably going to be
better off uploading the data to S3
first. Afterwards, we can reach back out
to the application server to create a
short URL for our paste. In the event
that this second step of the process
fails, we can safely retry the whole
thing from the start. As we can see in
the right side of the diagram, a
strategy like this can lead to orphan
files in our S3 bucket. Since S3 charges
per the amount of data stored, we
eventually want to clean these up. We'll
cover this in the deep dive section of
the video. When loading static content
from something like an object store,
using a content delivery network can be
incredibly useful to speed up the
requests. In the case of our site, keep
in mind that a small percentage of the
pace are going to account for a vast
majority of the clicks. In such an
event, we want to employ caching.
Content delivery networks are
essentially a set of caches distributed
over the globe specifically for object
stores. For example, Amazon CloudFront
is a CDN that operates on top of S3. All
you have to do is basically modify your
URL to say CloudFront as the domain
instead of S3. In the case of
CloudFront, if the content is cached to
the edge server itself, it's going to be
served directly. Otherwise, it's going
to be backfilled from S3. Each
CloudFront location uses LRU replacement
across many different applications that
run on it, not just ours to ensure the
popular content stays cached while other
content does not. Additionally, with
CDN, you have the option to specify a
TTL for content in the event that it
were to become stale and should be
removed. In our case, pastes are
immutable and we can't make any accurate
prediction on when a popular paste will
stop receiving traffic. Hence, we can
use the maximum TTL of 1 day and let LRU
replacement churn through items as
needed. Since we're emitting multiart
uploads from today's deep dive section,
this part of the video will mostly
around cleaning up orphaned S3 files.
Recall that in our tiny URL video, I
never explicitly created any process to
delete or clean up rows in our database
with expired URLs. I just allowed them
to be rewritten. This means that we
don't need some background process to
clear out database rows on some
interval. In the case of S3, we probably
don't want to do this. Depending on the
S3 storage tier, these costs can really
add up. Here's a thought exercise. Let's
assume that our pace are created and
expire at an even rate. At 600 million
pace created per month, that's 600
million expired pace per month. Assuming
that these are 100 kilobytes on average,
you can multiply those two numbers and
see that that's 57 terabytes of content
created per month that we need to
delete. If we don't purge it, the amount
of data that we store each month keeps
accumulating so that our AWS bill after
12 months accounts for 12 months of
paste creation. At 2 cents per gigabyte
stored per month, we can model this
problem as a cumulative sum. After 10
years, we'd rack up millions of dollars
in bills. One very simple way of
managing S3 objects is by using life
cycles. Life cycles are preconfigured
policies that can be attached to objects
which tells S3 to either move them to a
different storage class or get rid of
them altogether after some amount of
time. Note, however, that they need to
be preconfigured and then you can assign
a life cycle to an object at its
creation time. In our case, this is
super simple and we could create many
different types of tags to assign to
objects. This is great if we are willing
to support only a few predefined
expiration windows. However, if we want
to support arbitrary expiration times,
life cycles won't work for us. If we opt
to not use life cycles, we can instead
run code on a schedule that deletes pace
in S3 once they've lived past their
expiration time. There are many ways to
do this, so let's think about them. Keep
in mind that in our URL mappings
database, we keep track of URL mappings
and their expiration times. In theory,
this means that we can now run a SQL
query on this database to figure out all
of the S3 links that are now expired.
However, when a paste becomes expired,
the row corresponding to it in the URL
mappings table can actually be
overwritten before we run our batch job.
In that case, we would have no record of
the S3 link in our table so that we
actually know to remove it. What if we
just had a view of all of our S3 URLs
indexed by their expiration time so that
we could quickly reference it on some
sort of loop and delete URLs after they
expire? We can achieve this by choosing
smart names for our S3 objects. When
listing files in an S3 bucket, you
receive pageionated results returned in
lexographical order. Hence, we can
actually use our expiration time in
millie since epoch format to start the
name of the file. As long as all of our
time stamps have the same number of
digits in the string, they'll be
returned from the earliest to the
latest. In the event that we have many
pasts that want to claim the same
expiration time, we can just add some
extra characters at the end of the
object name. Our job can check these
against the current time and if they're
expired, delete them. This is the reason
that we need to pass in the proposed
expiration time when creating a signed
URL. The application server needs to
know what to name the object. Well,
guys, thanks for watching this video. As
you can see, it looks like I'm just
staring at my laptop screen the entire
time when I talk because I am. Um, I'm
going to do my best to answer all the
questions that come up, but uh again,
I'm going to give priority to all the
channel members. So, do please consider
getting one of those uh if you want to
fund any and all of my ludicrous and
gluttonous habits. I can't wait to see
you in the next one. I'm looking forward
to it.